this is this is Saturday before you go
out this is the night morning after the
walk of shame here so today we're gonna
try to guess which of these Amazon
products is rated higher than its
counterpart now I use Amazon so much
like I probably use it every single week
I
hundred percent golf ratings how many
people rate it and the stars can't just
dress like from the brand like the
seller to be like oh this products great
you should use it buying online you have
really no idea what you're getting until
it's at your door we're gonna start with
selfie lights this is already difficult
cuz I don't know how to turn it on okay
say yours has a little cord you have to
plug it in to your computer no that's
for charging Oh lights it up that's
pretty cool oh it's it gets brighter
okay looking like a car - you're like a
beauty blogger you would clip it onto
your phone
we can't tell because there's too many
lights alright so I'm gonna take one
without that much light it does like
define the gel and all that oh really
bright that's like the Sun even just
vlogging like look at this five star one
star I'm gonna say this one is the
higher rated I know a good selfie this
looks painful like that looks dangerous
that seems like yeah Mari does not like
this he's like no blue mouse thing it is
nice that you can just like pull it off
though it doesn't get any hair out look
like no hair sticks to this I can get
more fur off of him just going yes do
you see that that looks like tech this
looks like hardcore this is a tool this
is something you find in your shed wow
that's no dude yeah that is no joke I'm
gonna say this is the highest rated one
and that is a lower reader okay I would
say this is a lower rated product oh my
God we're so close to getting a Murphy
number two
Oh
[Music]
Oh there's so much this one's fuller
yeah it's definitely got a lot more hair
I have a little bit of hair oh I can try
to clip this into so is this like a
mullet situation I love this I'm having
way too much fun with this so yeah I
think this is a higher rated one that's
the little red one that I think we agree
I want to see mine is the better one it
just looks more natural it looks great
on dogs
I bought a party City wig and this feels
like Party City we poor thing this one
just needs a brush that one's snaps
smoother this is the 5 star
this looks like either a dog Dory or not
a dog toy or if it was made out of
something else like a really interesting
sex away how does it feel I hate this
you hate it hey God it seems like this
one can go in more crevices it's the
same to me I have no idea what's better
this black one definitely felt bouncier
and like more comfortable this is just
turning into a transformation video okay
I don't know if I can see the difference
but this one's way sturdier this is a
little highly rated product I think this
is gonna be the higher reviewed one yes
good I think we know which one is there
not the one uh-huh Oh what and that's
what Murphy was trying to tell us we're
so good at this we by way too many
things on the Internet this looks like
either a lipstick or a vibrator this is
beautiful I thought this was gonna be
lipstick you know what it's not
it is a vibrator this is horrifying
also it's beautiful just over the top
where do you shave this oh oh
personal news for the no I totally was
about to put this on my face and now oh
yeah it's not doing much have you ever
shaved you know this is 25 years of arm
here does it hurt no it doesn't hurt
how do I am the hair on the inside of my
elbow that's disgusting Wow okay that is
functional yes there it did a pretty
good job as there like some little hairs
okay already I feel like this one is
faster I am going to give this my
highest rating in disgust er yeah cuz
it's way faster because I think people
on Amazon are smart I'm gonna vote for
this one being the higher one for sure
that one for sure I think this one has a
lower rating what what this is higher
rated I would pick this one over that
one I like trust in the average user on
the internet still intact
I think 100% they were wrong yeah I
think for the most part we agreed with
the ratings yeah I got I will keep
relying on the reviews for sure and I
will keep using Amazon's
[Music]